So people sometimes ask is
how do you add those tabs
which show different parts of
a drawing that I have in all
my plans. So, in this video,
I'll show you how to do that
using Scenes
and Layers.
So let's open the table that I
have to run previous tutorials.
And so now to add those scene
tabs we go into a window
and then Scenes. And let's add
some scenes to this one.
Let's add 1 scene and
we'll call that one Main.
And you'll notice the tab has
appeared as soon as I added
the scene. And
let's add a second
scene. We'll
call that one
Assembly.
So, right now, those 2 scenes
are actually identical.
So, let's change the
view on 1 of these.
And I'll update
the assembly one.
And now if I click
on Main, you'll
notice it
transitions over to
what the Main scene
looked like.
Now that transition
takes 2 seconds.
Sketch-Up likes to
do these animations.
I find them a bit annoying
so let's modify that.
So let's go into Model info and
then under animation, it's set
to take 2 seconds so, let's
make those take half a second.
So we don't have
to wait as long.
So, now in the assembly view,
I want to show how this
goes together. So, I don't
want to have the top visible.
And let's pull
this joint apart.
So now, let's update that one.
Although that doesn't actually
do anything because
what I've now done is I
actually changed the model.
So, if I go back to Main
you'll see we actually have
the same thing and it's
modified. So, we don't
really want that.
So, I'm gonna hit Undo
a couple of times.
And what we want to do
is, we want to create
a separate copy of this table
that we're gonna modify.
So I'm gonna take
this whole table,
and I'm going to copy it,
just by doing a shift + drag
And I'm gonna make it
move 150 centimeters
this way.
So, I enter that down here. I
couldn't put the cursor on it
because that would
move the table.
So now let's go into
the Assembly view.
And this is what most people
will do, is they will
put these tables
far enough apart
that you can't see the other
one. So, imagine this was
several meters away, so
let's update that view.
And now I can take this
table and, for instance,
I'll delete
the top.
And so here we're focusing
on this one. And here
we've got the other one.
Now, personally, I don't
like to put these really far
apart because the drawing
can get really confusing.
So, this is where the next
part comes in so,
let's pop-up the layers.
Window, Layers.
And I'm gonna add 2 layers here.
There's already a
Layer0, which is the always
visible default layer.
So, I need 2 more layers.
And I'll call one Main
just like my Views. And I
call the other one Assembly.
So, let's take the
modified table
and we'll put that one
into the Assembly layer so
we'll right-click on
here, Entity Info.
And because we've got all
these pieces selected,
I'm just gonna make that
one part of Assembly.
And I'm gonna select the first
one. And I'll make that one
Main. So now these 2 are
actually in separate layers.
And I can turn these
on and off by
turning on and
off the layers.
So, in the
Assembly view,
I want to only see the Assembly
version and I'll uncheck
the main one. And which layers
are visible is actually
part of the scene. So, I'll
update the scene here.
And let's go back into Main.
And in the Main scene, I
don't want to see the Assembly.
And let's also
update that.
So now we can flip
between those 2.
Now the one thing I don't like
is how these things, kind
of, flip back and forth. I
would actually like these
to actually appear to be
part of the same table.
So, I'm gonna take the table
in the Assembly view,
which you remember I
moved that by 1.5 meters
to the right, 150 centimeters
so, I'm gonna move it back.
And let's click on Assembly
and now we need to change
our viewpoint. So, I'm
just gonna drag this over
so that we're, once again,
looking at where we actually
put the table. And I'll update
that. So, now if I click on
Main, you'll notice the table
appears to be the same
one, it's just the
top pops off.
And now, because these
things are actually separate
objects, I can take this
table and I'll turn it to
a bit more of an Assembly view.
So, let's tear apart
this joint here. And let's
also tear this joint apart.
And let's focus in on how
this joint goes together.
And we'll update the drawing.
And if I now go back
to Main, you'll see as I flip
through here it's very clear
that what we're looking at is,
in fact, this leg in the back
here.
Now the next thing we typically
want to do with drawing
is we want to add some
labels and dimensions.
So, let's start by adding a
label, and I just have to click
on here to get the label tool.
If you don't have
that toolbar selected, you
can find that under Tools
Text. So, let's call
this a table leg.
And now if we go
to the other view,
that label is not
visible because
that's actually
attached
to this table leg that's part
of this particular view only.
But if I now add a
dimension here,
so by clicking
on here,
or if you don't have the
toolbar visible, you go under
Tools, Dimension
and let's add a
dimension on here,
showing how big
this leg is.
Now the catch with that
one is, if I go to Main,
you'll notice this dimension
is still visible in here and
we really don't
want that.
And the reason is, when we
just drew this dimension,
it gets drawn into
the default layer.
So I can go in
here and I can
put this into the
Assembly layer
and now, just like everything
else that's in the
Assembly layer, it's not
visible in the Main view.
But, if I want to draw a lot
of these, its easier to just
select the current layer
as the Assembly layer,
and now if I add
more dimensions,
these all get placed
into the Assembly layer.
So, now if I
go into Main.
they're not visible. But this is
a bit of a tricky sort of thing
because, depending on which
layer we have selected,
sometimes if you
draw things,
it can get very
confusing.
Let me show you a pitfall of
this so, let's open this part
here.
And I'm gonna delete this and
I'm gonna select Assembly
and I'm going to redraw
this face and let's pretend
that I didn't remember that
I'm in the Assembly layer.
So, there's our
complete piece.
And now let's go
back to Main.
And let's close
all the objects.
And see now if we're in
here, in the Main view,
this part has a
side missing.
But as soon as we go
in the Assembly view,
it doesn't have it missing,
because this object
here. Let's go
into Entity Info.
This particular face is
part of the Assembly view.
And this here is
part of layer0.
So, in general, when drawing
objects it's best to draw
everything
is layer0.
We can fix that if we've
got everything as part of
whatever else. So, I'm just
gonna triple-click on here.
And select everything
to be part of
layer0 and that
fixes that problem.
So that's how to add
labels and dimensions
and deal with the whole
multiple scene issue.
And I'll talk a little bit
more about layers and
object behavior in my
next video, because
that's actually a kind
of a complicated topic.